you
[Music]
so hello and with this talk I want to
explore the making of software that
feels like magic and I want to start by
reflecting on people's responses to data
posture so this is the package that I
put on cran in 2016 and the community's
response to this was like beyond
anything I ever imagined lots of kind
words in emails and tweets even at this
conference we had some sort of news
headline a crossover with actual pastor
and a school that I don't fully
understand and amongst all that like
this little meme emerged and this brings
me a lot of joy even though I've never
spoken with anyone about this it's like
somehow I understand what's being said
here and I've experienced this myself
and I sympathize with this and you know
I I appreciate this so what is being
said I think you know the natural
definition of magic is like phenomena
that violate the rules of our world say
I think what's happening here is we're
violating people's assumptions about
what is within their power to do and
that is a pretty intoxicated feeling
when you suddenly like a shown you have
access to this power that you didn't
realize you had and I think mixed with
that is like some astonishment and
wonder that someone is just handing this
to you for free so that's what I want to
talk about with this you know talk I
want to give you three things so one is
like the general forms of tools that can
do this too is like some ideas about how
they do this and how you can do this
with the things that you work on and
three years like some broader ideas
about like how we can make sure we keep
seeing this type of stuff come out of
our community okay so chapter one our
packages is magic
let's go so this is a plot of a monthly
plot of the proportion of our stats
tweets that mention magic witchcraft or
sorcery and something pretty interesting
is happening in 2016 right like the rate
at which people are likening our to
magic has accelerated and is continuing
to accelerate
so who has a theory as to what this is
due to yes
tidy verse yes and we can confirm that
by tallying up the mentions of cran
packages within those tweets and you get
this like distribution of magical
mentions and the dark bars are the ones
that I think are signal the gray ones
are a bit noisy because of their names
so yeah but we've got some household
names up the top there but this is like
more or less what I expected to see what
I didn't expect was this so we've got a
really long tale of magic in our
universe and that is intriguing because
that suggests like there's a lot of like
lesser-known stuff out there to be
discovered so there's anyone interested
in discovering some of these yeah cool I
was banking on that obviously so what
I've done is I've like formed them into
categories because I think that's the
only way to sensitively discuss so many
I feel like this will be like five or
six natural categories and I'm gonna
talk about three today so the first one
is zaps and they remind me of the way
that magic works in Harry Potter because
it's like you have this tool and you
have this problem and you point and you
say the magic word and magic happens and
there's a problem that's solved and you
know the magic word might be like
install tiny tech in which case you know
the dependencies to knit a PDF will just
manifest themselves on your computer and
that's pretty powerful like depending on
who you are but the reason I'm showing
you this code is because I think this is
like the template for a SAP they often
have like one hero function that does
all the work and they tend to share a
name that function will share a name
with the package itself I'm so very much
like one function packages this is like
the largest category a few are the
interesting things so the most tweeted
about was here and I want to give a
special mention to janitor which like
although it has many functions like I
feel like it's like a spell book if you
like these little zaps some see also is
there for you later now I want to choose
you to genies so I call them genies
because they convey magic by some kind
of interaction with a program and their
goal is to assist you to do something so
they do this by creating like additional
you eyes we've asked you to do add-ins
or like console dialogues so they only
work in the interactive context
and I want to highlight an example
called map edit by team appellants and
not that it will allow you to like draw
geometry directly onto a leaflet and map
and then export that back into your art
session as a geospatial data set which
is pretty badass some seats see also is
there and now the third one that I want
to reduce you to is tongues and I know
if anyone's read this book it's pretty
good book but in this universe there's a
very strong theme of like the power of
words and a particular like the power of
names okay so that sorry so much so that
if you can discern the true name of
something like say the wind you can like
gain power over it yeah so that kinda
reminds me what's going on in this
universe and I don't think we can like
understate the contribution of the name
tidy data alone like it's an accessible
name we don't have the third normal form
Li verse right and and that name sets up
an intuition that is just confirmed by a
definition and that pattern plays out
all over the tidy verse like it's not
all magical but where it is you can just
navigate it with a cheat sheet and order
complete because the names of the
functions map so well to the problem
domain so this is not like unique to the
tidy verse I think the general pattern
of a tongue is it tries to create like a
new language freedom or easily Express
and solve a problem ok so these are like
three forms of tools that can you know
create magic for users and but what I
want to do now is talk about how are
they doing this like how are they
creating this feeling and how can you
create it with the things that you like
work on as well ok so he's like a idea
like talking about expectations being
violated I think we can frame that as
like maybe magic is the appearance of
you know when you're granted power
disproportionately to the pain that you
expected to like have to go through to
get that power I've got the like
subscript I there because I think it's
important to like acknowledge that this
is individual right because people have
different skills and experiences so
they're gonna see this a little bit
differently but what I noticed was like
when I started to look at the packages
in this set like they all grant power
definitely but they seem to like invest
a whole bunch of like dedicated effort
into taking away user pain and that
started me thinking like maybe this is
like it
maybe this is like the special thing so
I created this little litmus test and I
think this basically holds up I think if
you can like write this out convincingly
for a tool then there's probably a good
chance that someone will find that like
to be magical and it's pretty simple
like test it just goes like the magic of
tool is that it grants you power or save
me from pain and you put in like what it
does for power and what it like saves
you from for pain
so let's try to apply our magical deep
liar
is it a grants to your vocabulary for
wrangling data right now I haven't told
you the pain that it saves you and
because of that like deep liar sounds a
bit flat like base I can do this right
well magic of dupe liar
sorry is that it saves you feel like
mindless typing because of the placket
blintz face and non-standard evaluation
saves you from like having to read
because the functions are so well named
it saves you from having to learn SQL
because it will write that to a database
for you and that is pretty awesome so
let's go to tiny tech now I magic a tiny
tech is that it grants you the things
you need to know to PDF while saving you
from like bloated 4 gigabyte downloads
navigating you know ancient websites and
reading horrible instructions there's a
catalog of user pain associated with
setting up a lotta tech environment and
the author of this package equate has
like documented at all in this neat page
I think the link to this page is even
called like the hall of pain so this is
a really interesting thing to read like
if you want to get an insight into like
the mind of someone who is really like
in tune with user pain like equate
consistently creates things that people
perceive to be magical so the real value
of this little thing though I think is
that you can flip it and it can be a
design tool so if you're working on
something that you want to impune with
more magic like I think you just have to
like shove as much stuff into that last
section as possible right but you need
some ideas of like what you're gonna do
so obviously one place to start is like
what are my pain points when I'm doing
my own our analysis and I don't know
yours
alright but I know why and I can tell
you my top three so I hate mindless
typing and that's like typing where I
know what I've got a tired but I'm just
like waiting for my fingers to finish
this verbose like thing I hate reading
code I hate reading about code and I
hate making decision
about code because all these things like
take my mind off the analysis that I'm
trying to do and like put me into this
like code world where like often I
prefer not to be like well at least like
maybe not without my consent anyway
right so those are a bit abstract like
let's think about some concrete ways you
could like implement these so saving
typing like here's the continuum you
could like do the foil functions with a
non-standard evaluation you could use
the autocomplete friendly names to like
you know you only type part of it or you
could take the typing away completely
and that's why I do the data pastor like
a I really tried to bank heavily on that
for magic and I drill into like
minimizing the keystrokes to the
absolute so you can kind of guess from
that how much I hate typing and saving
reading well we've talked about the
intuitive names conforming becomes
really important when you are making a
model or a method right because what
your users fundamentally want to do with
a model or a method is compare it to one
they actually understand yeah and to do
that it needs to have like it needs to
look a certain way like it needs to take
a data frame use a formula interface and
return an object that implements certain
s3 methods and if it doesn't do that
like you're just wasting a whole bunch
of like reading and learning onto your
user like to allow them to make the
comparison that you know they want to
make so don't do that
um conform also be flexible so I think
potentially the worst kind of reading
you can do is like reading error
messages and then reading Stack Overflow
pages trying to resolve those right so
actually face R is really good at this
like besar will happily like convert
between lists and vectors and matrices
and data frames and all different types
of objects so if you create an interface
which is very rigid by comparison to
base are like it's gonna feel really
non-magical to people finally this is
like probably like one of the key
categories saving people decisions is a
really easy way to like make them happy
um so defaults are a way to do that but
I've had this like interesting
conversation with people about defaults
a number of times over the last year
where I've got this counter-argument to
defaults and I want to share it with you
so the argument goes so I could use a
default here but I'm worried them up
that my user will blindly use that
default
arrive at an invalid answer and then
blindly use that answer okay sir I guess
like my rebuttal so this is like why
does your tool give answers that users
can't like discern the validity of you
know so could you potentially invest in
some diagnostics or some things for your
users to you know be able to tell if the
answers right and if you did that you
know you've got like pain being saved on
the side path but there's no default and
pain being saved on the happy path you
know because you've got the default and
you just got a more magical thing
overall so in the middle there I just
want to slide two examples so there's no
way I would have released data pasta or
not for like dev tools and our hub so
these packages I see Jim and get more in
the front there
so these packages help you navigate like
the rat run of releasing an R package
like they give you little dialogues that
make you like help you think about the
right thing at the right time
so that's something that you could
emulate and finally I think like this
applies to all tools like just give
people less choices because for a user
to like make a confident decision they
have to kind of pause this choice space
and the more things you like tossing in
there like the bigger this space is
growing and the more I have to try and
understand it's like be confident so you
actually just creating anxiety from it
you know so like shrink that down reduce
my anxiety curate your experience and I
think like that will definitely make
something more magical so there's like
three pain points and then like three
ideas about how to address those
you'll have your own pain points and
your own ideas and like I'm really here
for that conversation but I just want to
switch up now to something a bit more
important which is like how can we make
sure we keep seeing more of this come
out of our community okay so I think
there's like a segment of our community
that is really in tune with use of pain
and we should listen to them and we
should learn from them and that's these
people in the red zone so these people
are not professional software developers
they are amateur software developers but
they're professional analysts and
they're professional scientists and they
are like living the pain everyday of
like having a problem having a tool and
having those not quite meet I think
it'll be their insights into those gaps
that will spawn like the next wave of
magical tools and that has the capacity
to
like a virtuous cycle when those tools
attract new users to our community all
right
and it's worth thinking about like how
much has have already created a bunch of
cool stuff for us like dad pasta
obviously written by total amateur but
like on a most significant level we've
got like knitter and ggplot and Sybil
now you know Chamber award-winning
package like these are all created by
students right were they wasting their
time writing our packages instead of
working on their thesis no like that's
garbage right so what I want to do now
is like for anyone who is like on the
cost is like committing to like
developing a tool that might take away
some pain I wanna like dispel a few
myths for you that might like get you
over the line I don't know
so the first thing I wanted to spell is
that for a tool be magical it needs like
a grand vision right so say like ggplot
is that gonna change the way you express
graphics okay but Don Foster is gonna
help you move text from this window to
this window on your screen and something
like glue is gonna like you know reduce
the code you write and make that code
more readable
as long as that code is for string
concatenation you know what I'm a X
heavy paste user I use glue all the time
and every time I do like I get a warm
fuzzy feeling so that's posted now the
second myth I'm gonna bust is that
magical code needs to smell good and
here I'm referencing Jenny Bryan's
amazing news our 2018 talk code smells
and feels and in this slide of that talk
jenny is discussing how the level of
indentation and nesting can be used as a
metric to identify code that could be
refactored so going for something on the
left there's something on the line yeah
cool so here's data pasta and look at
all that paste based based yes so like
like this is a little bit scary to me I
do feel like some pressure to rewrite
this but at the same time like I'm a
little bit scared that I don't fully
understand what's going on here anymore
and actually I don't mind having this
like a round this is like nostalgia for
me like this is what I thought writing
our code was only three years ago so
like I've come a fairly long way since
then
so it's nice to have this touchstone and
you know it helps to be in good company
so this is one of the most magical
functions on cran
there's some hints in there can anyone
pick it yes so this is Otto daughter
Rima from forecast and you just kind of
like fling at the time series it'll
catch it and churn away and give you
back the best model that it can which is
really awesome but yeah look there's a
bit going on there so this is good
enough for Rob Heineman this is good
enough for me it's good enough for you
and like the properties of your code in
no way correlate to the amount of magic
that it can make someone feel in fact it
might even anti correlate but that's
another story so now I want to make an
observation right I think would be
really cool if we had like an
organization in our community that was
dedicated to like welcoming amateurs and
making them like empowering them to
become tool makers right so we need a
forum and a website of course and that's
all like details details but what I want
to discuss right now is like the
important issue of like the logo that
we'd use for a hex sticker right yeah
they're very important so I want to
propose this motif this has been my
progress tracker up until now but it's
also a minor or anumana or blake
represents a pool of many magical energy
in like computer games and video games
and stuff like that right so we're in
our community so we drop an R on that
and it's like it's like someone already
had this idea right
and I'm like they're doing an alright
job so we'll let them keep running with
that but the reason that I'm showing you
this is because like I don't know if
this is a coincidence just like I don't
know if this is a coincidence like this
is like this is the the first a studio
comp at Harry Potter world you know and
it's like maybe there's something
embedded in our collective understanding
of what we're doing here I don't know
I've got some more examples that I might
blog or tweet or something but yeah I'll
leave that with you I'm gonna wrap up my
talk now so this is basically my idea
there are two ways to create software
that feels like magic number one is like
directly and you can you know create
something that passes this test take
away user pain and number two is
indirectly and you do that by supporting
these people our amateurs you know
listening to them and empowering them to
become tool makers so that's my talk
thanks very much for listening
[Applause]
thank you very much
miles for that wonderful talk the magic
of this talk of course was it gave
excellent insights and saved me from
trawling 14,000 cram packages to do this
work myself so we have two three minutes
for questions there's a gentleman with a
black shirt over there all right great
Sark so I feel like the distinction
between creating magic and then someone
calling it API obfuscation I feel like
is drawn between how much trust they
have right in what you're doing in the
functions that you're building right and
so as a student right developing a
package how do I build that trust in in
this the work that I do and and you know
make it so it's people can use it and
have trust in that what's working on the
back end is is reliable and and safe
yeah okay that's a really good question
so like if you develop something magical
and no one ever uses it like I guess
that's gonna be a real shame I mean I
can't really give heaps of advice like
when I created our pasta like I mean the
thing that got data pastor off the
ground really was that gif I tweeted
that gif and that just sort of went like
viral from there and I think the use
case was so compelling that like the
trust issue wasn't like what's the cost
here you know like if this doesn't work
for you and I often doubt a pastor
doesn't work for people but like you've
lost snuffing really you've lost a
couple of minutes and you'll go back and
you'll do this the normal way but if
this does work I could save you up a
whole bunch of time so I think it's a
combination of like making a compelling
case and also like putting it out there
yeah
there's a at the back check shirt thank
you so sometimes in software development
deep magic or dark magic is kind of a
pejorative yeah right so I'm wondering
about you know you're talking about
reducing user options and I think that's
generally a good idea but one of the
worst experiences is when the magic kind
of runs out and you find out that the
tool can't do the thing you want to do
so I'm wondering how you think about
balancing kind of exposing some of the
deeper workings of a thing and allowing
people to go deep when they when they
need to yeah I mean I actually think you
just have to really be led by your users
and listen to them and so like I
wouldn't like put those options in
speculatively but I guess I would try to
be really responsive and listen to what
people want you know and and listen to
the issues that are coming up on my mic
github and and people are tweeting about
so I guess just in time magic maybe
[Music]